when you think about bitcoin let's start
there uh where do you think bitcoin goes
from a price standpoint this year are
you a believer in this like super cycle
theory are you more a believer that you
know we kind of just go sideways how do
you think about bitcoin through the end
of the year
well you know i just said it's almost
pointless to have a three to four month
view but i know that's what you know
sort of people look at it look i was in
the hedge fund business and i had marks
every day and every week and
liquidity every month i mean i lived
that for you know 25 years you said
i just think that you know this is an
asset that's returned 250 annualized
over the last 11 years it's the greatest
return of any asset in the history of
the world i mean probably going back to
caveman times um so
i
don't think i mean i really am a hodler
i don't think you mess around with that
i i always thought and i've said
probably even a year ago i think that we
we're gonna get to around a trillion
dollar market valuation and then we
would consolidate
and that's sort of where we've done i
mean in my world view
forty thousand bitcoin fifty thousand
six hours it's all basically around the
same price
um
i think we could still get to 100
uh by the end of the year i
you know we might need some macro things
to happen i think that's more likely
sort of within six to 12 months
um
but
you know and i i think i've said this on
our our last interview and i even two
years ago that three four five hundred
thousand which would put the market
value at call it you know five six
trillion dollars
that was the first stop for me um you
know and i just simply
you know i've talked about this a lot
but it just in my mind
i think okay bitcoin you know the most
decentralized most secure network in the
history of the world the potential sort
of value protocol for the entire
internet okay
and it's worth a trillion dollars which
is roughly half of amazon which is just
one company so to me
i look at i think you know how much
would it cost even a company to to try
to build the bitcoin network from
scratch i mean it's trillions and
trillions of dollars so you know five
trillion dollar
market value is a
is a comfortable estimate that i am very
comfortable with in fact i called the
fund we called the fund 10t now 10t
stands for 10 trillion and what is that
well the market value okay when we
started thinking about this idea in 1920
i said the value of bitcoin ethereum all
the cryptocurrency and all the equity
in the space okay was around 300 billion
and i said well
i think we can go from 300 billion to 10
trillion in 10 years and so that's sort
of our mantra 10 t in 10 years but the
problem is we're at 3 trillion now
so
like we're a chip shot away from 10
trillion in 10 years i mean we we just
launched really in in january
and
we're already at 3t
so
you know the biggest mistake i've made
with all of this my the was i've
underestimated the exponentiality
of the growth in the space
um i just it's it's sort of not anything
that the mind can comprehend
and last thing i'd say on this though is
that what i was just looking at the
teaser for the fun that we wrote a year
ago
there were 20 businesses that we
identified with over a billion dollar
market valuation
today
there are 70.
just think about that
70 businesses
it's crazy to see there's a lot to do in
this space and
i presume i'll have you know there'll be
other people getting involved i mean
soon
when you think about uh the businesses
is it fair to say that your investment
strategy is essentially to invest in the
infrastructure uh and then your benefit
you're benefiting from like the overall
industry growth and the kind of that
index approaches you're basically
betting hey the industry is gonna be you
know much larger
hundreds of percent larger uh in the
future
and you want to bet on businesses that
are going to win as long as the industry
grows is that is that kind of a fair
character that's
that's exactly right um
you know that's exactly right i
i think uh you know we want to pay a
reasonable uh multiple of of revenue and
and earnings as well
um i mean i don't think there's a
company that we paid more than 10 times
revenue for
um you know we're were there there are
so many opportunities out there we're
very active in the secondary market as
well we speak to companies directly
um
you know i i'm not really willing to pay
25 or 30 times revenue
um and there are great companies that we
just passed on
um that will grow a lot uh just because
you know we don't have to buy everything
there there are lots of of great
companies but
um yeah i would say these are companies
that we think are core to the ecosystem
and you know the approach really was
it's a 300 billion dollar in you know
late 1920 300 300 billion dollar world
and we think it's going to 10 trillion
and so that's 30x and if it goes 30x if
we have a basket
portfolio
uh diversified nicely
of you know sort of broadly what you're
calling picks and shovels businesses
that are constructing you know the rails
of this new digital asset ecosystem
you know the odds are the portfolio is
going to go up and
i we don't need a 30x to be happy
um but we actually put that 10 t
obviously you know we're putting our our
uh you know we're eating our own cooking
on this one i mean i put it in the title
of the fun so
um
you know a portfolio
i think broadly is going to have such
wind at its back
that it should do well and again you can
see from the names that we purchased
um
that you know it is it is uh diversified
into those buckets and then these
businesses broadly do different types of
things so
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you